i'm a big fan of billions
i have plenty to talk to you about about
voyagers but i'm just doing it right now
actually i was shooting it until 10 a.m
at 12 2 a.m last night so yeah i was
just gonna see for a lot of people don't
realize i believe you held the first two
episodes and had been involved
yeah yeah yeah so um what did you ever
expect when you got involved that it was
going to be the
hit that it turned into well damien
lewis and paul giamatti it's it it was
like you know that bodes well for uh
for if it hadn't been it would have been
kind of a big disappointment those two
guys are
are you know amazing actors and
obviously everybody else in it is great
too but
as far as you know the two leading guys
so yeah i'm always obviously you're
always it's always a relief when it when
it works so
uh completely i could spend so much more
time on that but
jumping into another thing um if you
could get the financing together for
anything
tomorrow what would you make and why i
can't tell you that i actually do know
what that is
but i but i can't because i'm trying to
do it and i'm
superstitious i'm sorry to be kind of
cagey about it i'm like i don't even
tell like when i talk to my wife about
it i'm like don't you can't tell anybody
this
she's like look i'm not gonna tell
anyone so i can't tell you that but i do
have something
so so you're trying to say that you are
developing like the dream project right
now
i am yeah okay i'm now very curious
uh because i'm a fan of your movies so
i'm very i'm very curious what this is
i would tell you offline i i will i will
take it
just as a fan i will off the record
um so one uh i'm curious with this film
with voyages
how close did you actually get to
getting an r rating
pretty close like we got it and then we
had to
yank it back actually can i can i ask
what you was it like a few frames or
what did you have to do to adjust
a little more than that actually there
was quite a bit of blood and
you know there because there were young
people as well that suddenly is a red
flag if it had been a bunch of old
people
slaughtering each other um that doesn't
bother them but somehow the young people
because i think there's more young
people going and there was
we had a there was a lot of blood in the
movie that we had to pull back
actually does that mean uh at some point
you want to do like an
unrated extension i would actually yeah
i would so uh i could so drill
i was gonna say i could drill down on
that but um how long was your
was did you have a much longer cut then
well i mean you always start out with a
longer cut that you work your way down
to um and it's
you know in in some cases it's i mean i
think the cut works now because it's
it is so i mean i don't know how you
felt about it but
the people that seem to dig it are like
really
like the tension of it at the you know
in the second half and are just sort of
on the edge of their seat and feel kind
of unnerved the whole time and i think
the the pacing of that the pacing of the
the way the movie the way it is
is is that you know helps that and so so
i i i like it i think that you know as
you say there's a few other things that
we pulled out but it wasn't
it wasn't like we took massive sequences
out that i'm that i'm missing
one well something that i really enjoy
about movies like this
is when you take stuff that actually
could happen
and might actually happen in a few years
and sort of talk about it now
um and so can you sort of talk about the
fact that this film is not
as much science fiction as it's sort of
just looking at
our like the future and this could
actually be one of the paths we go down
yeah i think that's really right i mean
i tried to make it um
i wasn't interested in the fantasy of
space travel or something like that i
was interested in
in you know how they would really do it
um and we did a lot of research we
spent some time at spacex for example
and
other things as well and um you know
like what were these plans for you know
uh interstellar travel how would they
really work there's all sorts of
different propulsion systems and in a
way i went with kind of the most
minimal um version of it the less
the least fantastical and so then to do
that in a more conventional or the sort
of more conventional propulsion system
it's like
then it's like you've got to have weight
restrictions and which then
how much food can you have and how much
space can there be and so
that all helped toward the confinement
you know that sense of
um claustrophobia just because and and
minimalism they just have nothing except
the bare minimum to support life
and that they're you know they're
they're sort of always hungry
and um because they have to be
everything so rationed the thing that i
found interesting about this movie is
there it could go in so many different
directions
you could have spent more time on earth
uh i
wear the movie and like there's there's
so many choices this is a big story
yeah i'm just curious did you ever think
about this as like a series did you
always envision it
i i have i've kind of written it as a
series too like before like
before you know i i wrote this the
screenplay a
number of years ago and then it got kind
of um
uh you know i was working on other
things so it was sort of
sitting there and that certain people
come by and they're like oh we love that
why don't we do that when we do that as
a tv series so i sort of work it out as
that
but i you're right all that stuff about
on earth and things like that i have it
all i know like
richard's whole backstory in life i
could make a you know
i could make a movie on that before they
take off you know
um so and we're talking about it as a as
a series as well
well you did that with limitless i did
and i was like i
yes yes we did do that so yeah i mean
uh i actually like that series and i i
really like that movie
um before before i run out of time i
believe you're partnering up with daisy
ridley
on a project i am yes we're doing a
movie called the marsh king's daughter
which is based on a
best-selling novel and it's this kind of
a beautiful thriller about this young
woman that's been um
raised in the wilderness by her by her
parents and uh
and then learns that her her all was not
as as it seemed when she was when she
was a child and it
and then it's then she's daisy's
character as an adult
you know sort of um having to uh
confront
uh and go sort of head to head with her
with her father
can i ask when you're shooting that yeah
this summer yeah
oh okay so it's going really soon i'm
prepping it right now
yeah and shooting billions at the same
time jesus
uh well uh first world problems yes
right i already got to go i'm just going
to say that please
uh share offline uh let me know what
you're doing because i'm very very
curious